[Music]
in jest first job news best first job
best first job I think I had that what
is it was her first job I was a barista
at a book shop so I would like when it
was it was College a book shop so when
it was the beginning of the semester
it'd be [ __ ] packed so it was fun I
just selling books and then when I was
super slow I would just make coffees and
juice I was a gender where my dad's
business oh yeah I remember you saying
that I was like if did you have like 70
keys no no there was actually didn't
even had keys you weren't a real janitor
what do you mean no looks like some
retina scanning place no it was just
like when it was open I would do all the
toilets and all the [ __ ] sinks and
all action what was the weirdest [ __ ]
you had a seat [ __ ]
yeah just actual human [ __ ] they
wouldn't flush the toilet ax man when
people can do things that were there's
no like way to find out who you are yeah
or what you did they do filthy
disgusting things sometimes I walk into
a bathroom right and I just see pee
everywhere
nice did you blast off from the pressure
of your penis like this way at the
airport it's hard finding a clean toilet
at the airport yeah like water jetpack I
want to know I want to see the footage
and what happened okay you you knurled
where your penis goes to die we have
very nice you know they just peepee on
the ground towards eat I wish the guy
who's on the toilet see how about that
it's on the bottom my [ __ ] shoes
where I pictured like a penis it can
just go like that she can just go crazy
but my real problem is that like when I
go into the women's bathroom and there's
pee everywhere like y'all I've been like
yeah that doesn't move you cannot pull
the urethra out and even you find P like
a lot on the wall I think it's the girls
that are squatting and then they'll just
pee all over the seat but they don't
wipe it you do that [ __ ] you dude I want
somebody to tell me a legitimate story
of how they feel
she's in the restaurant and the PIA
ended up everywhere like give me a good
excuse because there's I don't get it do
sometimes though as a guy if you're at
your house and you have light morning
wood yeah she's so [ __ ] annoying cuz
it's it doesn't peak correctly so you're
over here trying to aim I thought I'd
die put my hands on the top window
because I don't know what's gonna happen
Lisa [ __ ] yoga poses yeah you have to
you have to like have you ever tried to
pick up [ __ ] like well you don't want to
bend your legs right so you have to just
[Music]
know if I have morning wood and I know I
gotta go to the bathroom and I'm like I
don't know what's about to happen about
Mugsy get out I'm like well here we go
wait why are you guys so stupid why
don't you guys just go into the shower
and then just what do it up cuz I've
done that in the shower yard me you
don't rape if you [ __ ] rinse it real
quickly
no problemo cuz the penis is pointed up
there when I run the water tool is I'm
wasting water we were wasting water
because you're brushing your teeth which
is a two minute thing yeah you have you
think all the whole times I want it to
be hot I get in there do you know how
much water that we have on the planet
Earth so much [ __ ] water the plants
covered in water not usable it is if you
build a desalination plant tip and we
have those that are like effective that
entire planet yes yeah we could build as
many as we want anyway we haven't gotten
to the submitted by yeah submitted by
Christmas in October that's weird
no Christmas all year round I'm with you
yeah people are generally nicer during
Christmas though I who doesn't like
Christmas because it's sad it's because
people give me presents and I feel like
I have to give them back and like I
don't [ __ ] up humbug you get too many
presents around Jessie's watching this
right now and she does even get one
present
just as watching this right now she just
put her hand on the screen while both
said that she only gets presents for
Christmas teenage years I kept on my
family like don't give me thank for for
us don't give me anything don't give me
min so finally in the last three years
they stop getting me presents and now I
feel a lot no I feel better I feel guilt
free like less guilty you know because
I've never gotten them [ __ ] I haven't
gotten a gift from my presence in year
from the kerosene years yeah it feels
weird getting a gift from my parents now
me too yeah I'm old enough that I should
be giving it back to base Jackie yeah
yeah like but I mean I just you know I'm
in social fishing my whole life I've
been in the game a long time so I
couldn't I can't take [ __ ] what I like
about Christmas isn't even the present
it's like it just it feels like cinnamon
time like the [ __ ] Rain Man over here
dude like Christmas tree time no pine
trees made me happy no you will get a
nice Christmas okay yo you'll feel it
you're feeling thank you let's do his
child it's so sad dude like we would all
say like don't you love Christmas and
the tip will be like yeah when you get
to get a Christmas tree and then he'll
be like yeah when you get to boil soy
sauce and closet for very long you know
what you want ginger for three hours
Christmas McDonald's launched a program
to help its employees kick-start their
dream careers in various fields that's
awesome yeah we'll see how effective
that is McDonald's University there's
great marketing for McDonald's you know
I'm not salty because I'm just not gonna
get that brand deal ever you know nervin
what say it say it I'll say it right now
nothing was it a pun about salt in them
they probably got a brand deal and you
did it
I literally dressed up as Ronald
McDonald for Heisey you too thirsty
though that's too thirsty it's the non
McDonald [ __ ] Casey's gonna who secretly
eat McDonald's like behind everyone's
back to them but he complains about it
all of us he gets the artisanal [ __ ]
chicken sandwich in front of people I am
talking so much [ __ ] about McDonald's
starting from now let's go continue this
give me dollars after this god damn it
all right so they started this new
program or campaign is called the where
you want to be campaign and it will
allow select employees to be paired with
mentors and five fields arts and
entertainment technology
entrepreneurship health care and
restaurant and food service that's tight
what's the technology sector at
McDonald's it's like a better whippin
machine for the coffee no ice cream
machines not broken oh yeah [ __ ] fix
that with a [ __ ] saucer but she's
always broke it [ __ ]
no milkshakes after night because they
don't want to clean the machine I know
the real thing yeah I read about it on
reddit yeah like Tyler Oakley is gonna
be the mentor for technology makes sense
Thank You Bart everyone knows who he is
I'm sorry Tyler Oakley is gonna sit down
with thousands of McDonald's employees
hey we like Tyler Oakley why is it Mark
Zuckerberg the authority no but I'm
saying
Tyler Oakley is gonna sit down and talk
to thousands of McDonald's employees
know so they're only selecting one
employee for each category for this
thing how everybody mentors are able to
get but they did mention Tyler Oakley
wait for technology but what does he
have to do with tech why did he get
marques Brownlee or something because
you don't like Tyler Oakley I said that
but yo says I don't like Tyler Oakley
that's more like marketing dude like
mkbhd that's the salty AF no James alter
do you know it sounds like a racist to
me he's an angel investor author and
podcaster he will be teaching out of a
hash mark
and we exactly food sector that would
make sense see Tyler Oakley could go to
the entrepreneurship that makes more
sense about the technology rush agree I
don't know he's either but he does come
out in TV show Empire and he's and he's
the mentor for the arts and
entertainment okay that's a proper fit
yeah and then this dermatologist who
graduated from Harvard Medical School
will be the healthcare mentors yeah and
then McDonald's will try this so they
said let me down to a tap into its
franchisee Network for mentors in the
foodservice category and then they're
saying that they're probably gonna have
the most employees in that category
because they might have a lot of mentors
in that category but yeah so they're
just saying that they are really they're
hoping that this program could grow and
just have helped their employees to try
to achieve oh they're also gonna be
offering free job counseling career
services advisor and then starting next
year the employees will able to we'll be
able to explore career opportunities
through a new mobile tools out of like
millions of employees only five people
the only five people I get this for this
five people benefit those is right this
is just advertised this is just
marketing yeah that's it nailed it you
smelled it from the jump I did I did
yeah and you know what Reese's had a
good marketing campaign the other day
Reese's how to fire those Reese's
Reese's peanut butter cups and recently
say recently I know it restart the EC is
I'm sorry I thought it was I've never
heard anybody sees Peter Pan I've only
heard Reese's what are you absolutely
talking about you're a [ __ ] Reese's
dude you're Reese's three seasons recent
telling you you're saying it wrong no I
agree with her oh you're seeing it wrong
Reese's Peanut
we see that you
and to ease its re sis Reese's Pieces
its Reese's Peanut burger this is after
26 years you're not gonna just take this
ever listen to the commercials 33 long
arduous here the commercials risa season
8 cups oh my god I think you're right at
weight place I think you're right I
think they do say Reese's yeah they say
I'm gonna double down on this and say
absolutely the [ __ ] did you put money on
this right now scheme wait this title
says you may have been pronouncing
Reese's wrong this whole time watch
somebody come up we swap do it okay this
is like some Berenstein bears [ __ ] yeah
I feel like it is cuz if there was
bernstein or Bernstein yes it was a
Bernstein I'm always like oh I'm getting
so nervous
Steve I'm getting nervous we're getting
nervous we're getting nervous okay
haters all gone and prank video take one
Reese's recent Reese's okay so they
great marketing campaign they were like
what do the people want good candy so in
New York there's this machine where you
can turn in your shitty candy in
exchange for recently right it's just a
vending machine like in various areas in
New York and like it was trending on
Twitter and like that right that's some
good-ass marketing how cheap was that
you know cuz you know what's so funny
about McDonald's they're like well we're
going to start this bride hopefully we
can expand your a billion dollar company
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
hopefully you can expand you're gonna
started way bigger and it wouldn't have
done [ __ ] to your company oh yeah
absolutely and they were like hi Tyler
Oakley would you like to partner with
McDonald's on this venture and he's like
sure I'll make a hundred grand from
eating at a McDonald's employee for 30
minutes yeah
and I'll tell my life story one time and
say yeah I gave them a technology update
well they get the shadow then grow all
day okay
yeah
[Music]